خرجت الجماهير المغربيه الى الشوارع
والساحات الكبرى والميادين للاحتفال بتاهل
منتخبها لدور ال16 لكاس العالم في قطر
2022 ونزل عشرات الاف المواطنين حاملين
الاعلام ومرتدين قمصان ابرز لاعبي المنتخب
المغربي الذي تصدر المجموعه في السادسه
بسبع نقاط بعد ان فاز على كندا بهدفين
لهدف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مغربي مغربي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عادل الزبيري مساء الخير عادل بدايه مبروك
لك ولكل المغاربه هذا الانجاز الكروي
الكبير الذي يذكر بامجاد الكره المغربيه
عام 86 لوضعنا في اجواء الاحتفالات التي
سادت كل المدن المغربيه بعد هذا الانجاز
مرحبا ابراهيم هذا فوز مغربي وايضا فوز
لكل الدول العربيه في مونديال قطر مونديال
العرب لولا الاجواء المغربيه البارده هذا
اليوم سقوط المطر لكانت الافراح ومستمره
الى الان عدت للتو من شارع محمد الخامس في
قلب العاصمه المغربيه الرباط وتركت اخر
المشجعين الذين لا يزالون الصامدين رغم
بروده الطقس في اجواء احتفاليه مغربيه
عامه مدن وقرى وجبال وسواحد المغرب المغرب
اليوم في عيد كرويا يعيد تحقيق انجاز
مكسيكو 86 عندما كان المغرب اول منتخب
عربي وافريقيا يمر الى الدور الثاني احلام
المغاربه ترتفع وسقف الطموحات يرتفع
والرغبه الان في تحقيق حلم اخر تجاوز
المنتخب الاسباني هذا الفائزين في مونديال
همم العالم لكره القدم والتاهل لملا لاول
مره في تاريخ الكره المغربيه الى دوري رب
النهائي طبعا الشيب والشباب والصغار
والكبار كلهم هتفوا من وراء همم همم
الاسود الاطلس الكل كان يمني النفس
بالتاهل الى دوري الكبار الدور الثاني دور
المغلوب كما يسميه المعلقون الرياضيون
الان الاماني المغربي والاحلام المغربيه
تكبر تابعنا مسؤولين مغاربه رفيع المستوى
ايضا حضروا هذه المباراه
وشجعوا وهتفوا وخرجوا عن تحفظهم باعتبارهم
مسؤولين
عباراتفوا بهذا الانجاز ام انهم
يطمحون للمضي ابعد من ذلك خصوصا وان
المنتخب المغربي ربما كان اكثر المنتخبات
العربيه تكاملا وانسجاما وثباتا فيما
يتعلق باللعب هل يرى المغاربه بان اسبانيا
ستكون لقمه سائغه هل كانوا يفضلون ان
يلتقوا المانيا التي غادرت المونديال
لوضعنا في صوره التوقعات بخلال يعني هذا
اليوم الذي كان حافلا ربما بالمفاجات
ابراهيم يتوفر المغرب اليوم على افضل
منتخب كروي في كل تاريخ الكره المغربيه لم
يتوفر للمغرب مثل هذا المنتخب نجوما
لاعبين يلعبون في انديه عالميه المغاربه
اليوم يقولون ما حققناه اليوم انتهى
طموحات المغاربه الان تقارب السماء الشارع
الرياضي المغربي يريد الان دوري الربع
اسبانيا ليست اقوى من بلجيكا وليست اقوى
من كرواتيا المغرب وقع في قرعه كاس العالم
في الدور الاول في مجموعه لقبت بمجموعه
الاموات تعادل مع كرواتيا وهي لعبت نهائي
كاس العالم في روسيا 2018 اداء كروي غير
مسبوق في تاريخ الكره المغربيه في مواجهه
بلجيكا وانتصار ومستحق الاسود الاطلس في
مواجهه منتخب يحسب له الكبار الف حساب
بلجيكا اذا الان المغرب امامه اسبانيا
منتخب روسيا الريكي منتخب قاعد بنجوم
صاعدين في نادي برشلونه على وجه الخصوص
وايضا اسماء قادمه من البرايمليك المغرب
ايضا لديه حارس مرمى يلعب في الدوري
الاسباني لديه نجوم يلعبون في كوبايات
الدوريات المغربيه مباراه المغرب واسبانيا
ستلعب على تفاصيل بسيطه وصغيره جدا ستمكن
الفوز لاحد المنتخبين كرواتيا وبلجيكا دخل
هذا المونديال بتوقعات وترشيحات كبيره جدا
اسبانيا ليست لديها توقعات بحس بحسابات
الاوراق
يعني انت مثلك مثل كل المغاربه تحولتم
يعني الى يعني خبراء في الكره وهذا ربما
شان كل مغاربه الذين يعشقون كره القدم انا
اشكرك ونتمنى التوفيق للمنتخب المغربي في
مقابله القادمه مع اسبانيا وايضا ان يمضي
ابعد في هذه البطوله شكرا جزيلا لك عادل
الزبير كنت معنا من الرباط